l'histoire du chevalier du chevalier
d'éon est absolument incroyable
effectivement il a été envoyé par louis
15 auprès de lazzari la bête parce que à
l'époque la guerre de sept ans se
préparer et on avait besoin d'alliances
et en particulier de des russes qui
étaient beaucoup plus proche des onglets
et donc toutes les ambassades avait
échoué et finalement le shaykh on est
allé là bas sous le nom de l'oea de
beaumont que donc et a réussi à être
auprès d'eux lazzarini et ces races si
vous voulez à sa proximité avec la
divine et tout son entourage qui
effectivement est bien les russes se
sont rapprochés de la monarchie
française
voilà après parce que c'est fantastique
a pris il revient il combat pendant la
guerre de sept ans avec son grade de
capitaine des dragons dont il était très
fier il est blessé on peut dire c'est
pratiquement un héros il repart après à
londres où il y aura plein de malheur
mais où surtout il arrivera à voir alors
là il est évident comme il arrivera à
voir les
il arrivait à subtiliser lors d'une
soirée fastueuse qu'il aimait bien donné
avec fox victuailles et surtout beaucoup
d'alcool ils arrivent à se constituer
les notes dans lequel
on voyait jusqu'où les anglais étaient
prêts à aller dans les concessions dans
ce qui sera le désastre était de paris
donc c'est grâce à ça que des français
en sus jusqu'où ils pouvaient aller
alors ce traité de paris a été
désastreux
mais on peut imaginer que 107 ce
renseignement a mené par des on va il
aurait été encore pire
[Musique]